from at colton mason 86 if drew brees
continues to show
he's not what he wants was what week if
any would they
make a change and who would get the
start i don't know how long sean payton
can keep his steve young
on the bench sharing it seems premature
to have the conversation
i don't know though i mean there are
people who are having a conversation
there are people who are asking the
questions have
have you developed any feel any gut
sense as to whether or not we could
actually see drew brees get yanked off
the field before he's ready to retire
you know i think sean payton's brilliant
i got to know him when he was in dallas
as the offensive coordinator under
bill parcells and he always seems to
find a way to do things
i don't want to say the right way but
you know you have to do this gracefully
you can't just go
sit it was almost like the eli situation
but but
even more so because drew brees is the
all-time
leading passer in so many categories and
you can't just go
say we're going to sit you down drew
brees i mean it just can't be done like
that but
sean payton has managed to use multiple
quarterbacks
over the last few years and he is one of
the most
creative offensive geniuses in the game
i just think he's going to find
some way when they need to throw the
ball down the field
it is no secret i don't care what drew
brees says it is no secret he cannot
throw the ball down the field
we've seen it over the last couple years
we've talked about it a lot
his longest uh pass the other night was
29 yards and it was a catch and run by
traequan smith
he has 4.82 air yards after two games
that is the lowest
of any quarterback since brett favre in
2009. he is not getting the ball down
the field they have to find some way to
do that
i know michael thomas wasn't there i
know that hurt that offense
but he can't get the ball down the field
it's just a fact
there was a throw against the buccaneers
and it was only one but it shows he's
got the capacity he did get the ball
down the field i think it was like 40
yards in the air
so you know every once in a while he can
uncork one the question is can he do it
reliably can he do it consistently can
he have accuracy
if he's muscling it as far as he
possibly can and for the most part that
offense is premised on quick
timing short passes swing past the
screen passes
crossers that aren't going to be in the
air for very long and he runs that
offense very effectively the problem the
other night was
when it was 17 to 7 it just felt like
the saints were ready to put the hammer
down and the next thing you know it was
going to be 31 to 7 like we've seen so
many times in the past
where we turn off the game at halftime
or only barely pay attention to it
because it's another example of a
of a saints team that just suffocates
the opponent because the offensive
efficiency is too relentless for the
other team's offense to keep up with now
in this case
the saints defense didn't hold up its
end of the bargain but the offense
lost its footing and never could really
get back to the point where they were
moving the ball efficiently and scoring
points they had
plenty of yards but they couldn't cash
in and that's what was so vexing and
i look i see the saints are a
three-point favorite on sunday night and
frankly and again not to tip too many of
my picks for this week because in the
event that sims finds out about this he
may factor it into his picks for
tomorrow
i'm surprised the saints are three-point
favorites when you look at what the
packers have done so far this year
and we look at what the saints have done
or have not done so far this year
and i think there's a chance it could
get
i don't want to say ugly on sunday night
but there's a chance it could be
lopsided
and there's a chance that the narrative
will be
more prevalent come monday when we see
on the same field on the same night
aaron rodgers
and drew brees and aaron rodgers is
still going to be doing aaron rodgers
things
and drew brees limitations are going to
be put on display for everyone and the
question is what would sean payton ever
do about it
you know there was the report that came
out on the first day of the season one
of the
many sunday splash reports shireen
suggesting that the saints had interest
in tom brady even after
drew brees said he was coming back and
you just wonder
at what level there's something
percolating and how sean payton would
handle i don't think sean payton would
ever bench drew brees
i think sean payton would go to drew
brees and convince him he has an injury
right to help him save some face so he
wouldn't be yanked off the field for
taysom hill
but you know if it goes poorly on sunday
night
and then they stumble into their bye
week they've got lions
in detroit and the chargers at home on a
monday night before they go into their
buy
i i think that that if they don't
turn around their offense from what we
saw on monday night
and they and they struggle offensively
the next three games there we may find
out during the bye week that there's
some sort of
injury to drew brees and the taysom
hills getting the start on the other end
can you see them though mike playing
multiple quarterbacks whether it's
a combination of the three quarterbacks
or
taysom hill takes more snaps and throws
more i mean you sighted one deep throw
in two weeks that's
not enough in in two games can you see
them playing multiple quarterbacks more
than what they've done so far because
they have kept taysom hill and bubble
wrap so far
well i remember when we had drew brees
with us at the super bowl and we talked
about the possibility of hill
returning and getting more of a workload
because we had seen him do so many
special things in the playoff loss to
the vikings
and drew brees said hey i'm fine with it
however many plays that now it's one
thing to say it
in january it's another thing to be okay
with it come september
and we've seen taysom hill used less
frequently and the thing is
you know look these guys are paying
attention everything that's said
publicly about drew brees not having the
deep ball every time they let taysom
hill throw a deep ball
that is the proverbial needle in the
lung
to drew brees he doesn't want to see
that he doesn't want to be disrespected
so i i think that that that's part of it
and and
he's earned that respect right i don't
fault him for being potentially prickly
about the idea that he's being nudged
off of the field
uh you know because he could say to the
saints why didn't you just tell me
in the off season you didn't want me why
didn't you just tell me it was over then
uh instead of bringing me back and not
letting me be the quarterback of the
team so i think it's a delicate
situation
you're right though i think sean payton
will handle it the right way but if this
offense doesn't turn it around they're
going to have some decisions to make if
they want to truly be a contender this
season shireen
yeah no question about it mike and and
that offense needs to play better
they had that interception right before
half time that that really killed them
and they just couldn't respond in the
second half so as great as drew brees
says he's
he feels he needs to play great this
week for the pa for the
saints to have a chance and to turn this
thing around and be the team that we all
thought they could be because we
we picked him as the first or second
best team in the nfc going of the year i
think everybody would have said that
at maximum overdrive right now who has
the best chance of getting the first
pick in the draft do you think that by
the end of the season that team will be
in search of a quarterback and are they
capable of surrounding him with the
necessary talent your thoughts sharing
it's so early and there's so many
contenders but i think you have to go
with the jets at this point 32nd and
offense
19th in defense i wish the jets and
giants played because i'd like to see
that
match up for perhaps the number one
overall pick
now you go back to to the cardinals and
what they did they drafted josh rosen
with the 10th overall pick and then the
next year they had the number one
overall pick and they said
forget that we don't care we're going to
cut our losses we're going to trade josh
rosen for whatever we can get for him
we love kyler murray he's our guy we're
going to draft him and
you could see the jets doing a similar
thing now sam darnold's had more time
but i could very well see the jets going
we have the number one pick we have
these multiple picks we can build a
really good team here if if sam darnold
doesn't
develop as they think he will this year
i could very well see them going out and
get trevor lawrence
hey you know what i'm already looking at
a team like the vikings when they're on
scholarship this year and everyone's got
their financial security now they have
to get
rid of kirk cousins and i wrote earlier
today that but for maybe a trade to the
49ers they're going to be stuck with a
ton of money on the books for 2021 and
2022 but
once a team falls out of contention it
pays off to be as bad as you can be
because it gives you the highest
possible
draft position and somebody's getting
trevor lawrence and it's going to be one
of these bad teams all right one more
question speaking of the vikings t lions
122
why do our vikings continue to be the
toby flenderson
of nfl teams i don't think they're the
toby flenderson
i i had a chance to consider this i
think they're
the jim halpert here's why because jim
halpert
is a screw-off he doesn't get his work
done
he's always looking into some but he
always does just enough
to not get fired and and you know so he
follows every good day
with a bad day he makes his big sale and
then he goes and he does something he
shouldn't do and then he comes back and
he makes a sale that's what the vikings
are they ping-pong between goodyear and
bad year
so they've got this this sweet spot they
found where they've got job security for
everyone
but they're never going to be as good as
they can be
29th and total offense 29th in total
defense i don't know if there's been a
worse team in the nfl i guess you look
at the teams that they've played
but they have not been good and
certainly are a contender for that
number one overall pick right now
i say go for it once you know you're out
go for it get trevor lawrence you have
your quarterback situation taking care
of over the next 15 years
and embrace being bad because it can
lead potentially
to good things hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports